speak now to the new leveling up housing
and communities secretary simon clark
previously chief secretary of the
treasury mr clark love you to have you
with us good morning your time this
morning it's going to be a busy day for
you guys of course this new
administration how far off were we with
our prediction of the way that this
package is going to work well as you'd
expect i can't preempt the prime
minister's announcement today but what
you're absolutely right in saying is
that the government is going to be
taking meaningful action to address the
concerns which viewers will be feeling
and which of course aren't restricted to
family finances they affect businesses
as well
so that we can have certainty for the
country about what we're going to do
over the course of the winter ahead we
all know that
as a consequence of what putin has done
in ukraine and his attempt to weaponize
particularly gas as a
as a way of trying to break the west
resolve in terms of standing up for
democracy uh that there are really
tumultuous events in the energy markets
we need to provide a solution which
doesn't just address this in a way which
means that we keep coming back to it
which provides a lasting framework for
how we're going to sort this uh for
people over the months ahead now just
the proposals because i i respect that
you will not tell us what the plans are
you want to prove to the prime minister
but just the proposals have led to some
turmoil in the markets the pound's at
its lowest level since 1985. i mean it's
not the market's telling you that
whatever you're proposing is gonna be
really damaging and dangerous to the
economy well we all obviously would
never want to find ourselves in this
situation and there's there's no
question that you know this is the
latest in a series of quite
extraordinary interventions that the
government has had to make to support uh
families and you know which obviously
reflect our absolute determination to do
the right thing uh for the british
people but let's be clear if we fail to
act if we don't uh protect the economy
against the shock of the size and scale
that we're talking about then there's
going to be enormous economic damage uh
in any event so the hardship that the
not just the october price cap but the
forecast january and then april
iterations would would cause would be
enormous and we're already hearing from
businesses and this is something i was
obviously hearing in my former treasury
role about the the deep concerns they
have about their energy bills and so you
know we could have anticipated i think a
huge amount of damage to the economy had
this had this rise gone ahead unchecked
so you're balancing frankly two uh very
challenging things
in these circumstances i think the
country will say and i think markets
will respect that this is the most
sensible thing to do well i mean respect
is one thing but their reaction is
another and of course the markets will
behave as they think is is uh in their
best interests and it would seem as if
economists people who are doing these
kind of forecasting don't trust this
plan that's coming forward well if you
look at the uh the uk's most recent
round of uh of debt issuance you know
that was well covered uh you know there
was there was much more demand for our
for our debt than was needed to uh cover
the latest auction we're paying around
three percent uh for uh for our our debt
that's that's a perfectly sustainable
level the uk is obviously a very stable
very strong economy subject uh you know
to a very clear regulatory system and
the rule of law we are a safe bet and a
safe haven as we always are frankly in
these kind of situations and the
government is clear that a fiscally
responsible approach sits at the heart
of our plans but we we cannot fail to
respond to the magnitude at the moment
this trust is clear that you know as
prime minister her first priority this
week is to is to provide that certainty
and i think you know this is something
which notwithstanding the fact it's
difficult it's bold it's brave we have
to do because the country can't really
think about anything else until we've
done this uh well with the idea of debt
in mind then the prime minister ruled
out the idea of expanding the windfall
tax um
stuck with a plan on corporation tax as
well so in the future that debt burden
is going to be much much higher isn't it
well you know as as with the financial
crisis in 2008 and as with the covis
situation the government has to respond
to these major crises and then uh deal
with the deal with the consequences in a
measured way over over time but the
prime minister is rightly clear that we
cannot keep on with the mindset that we
can tax our way to growth we can't keep
doing that
we need these oil and gas companies to
be focusing on more extraction an
extraction of north sea gas is up 26
compared to this time last year which is
fantastic we need to see a lot more of
that because the reality is energy
independence is the lasting solution to
the situation we are in and we can never
again and this is the wider context of
this strategy find ourselves in a
situation where we are reliant on others
for the things that we need we've got to
get much closer to self-sufficiency
these companies are absolutely critical
to that happening and happening at the
pace we need i mean self-sufficiency is
of course what everyone will want but
you were chief secretary of the treasury
so kirsten were quite a treasury figure
yesterday said 170 billion pounds in
excess profits is going to be made by
energy uh energy companies might i mean
is that those correct figures look the
the reality is that if companies are
making large profits then of course they
will also be paying large amounts in tax
to the exchequers and there's already a
windfall tax which was introduced
earlier this year and critically it's
worth remembering that oil and gas
companies pay double the main rate of
corporation tax they pay 40 p in the
pound compared to 19p as the main rate
so it's not as though they don't pay
their fair share of taxation but these
are the people who are going to be
delivering that next generation of
nausea oil and gas investment we've got
all of these fields that we frankly need
to bring on stream as quickly as
possible you know labour will always say
because it's in their dna the solution
is to tax tax tax actually what we need
is to invest and to grow this is how we
do that yeah i mean let's stick with 170
billion you haven't said those figures
are wrong so that is that is a correct
estimate well no i'm not i'm not going
to confirm or deny uh figures which i i
i said today you didn't recognize those
specific figures okay look there's a lot
of money that could be got from taxing
these oil and gas companies more and
you're deciding the government is
deciding to put all that money onto the
country's credit card there was a time
when that was seen as fiscally
responsible the conservative government
said that was fiscally what now is it
what we do is we is we fix the roof when
the sun is shining the sun is
conspicuously not shining right now this
is a global storm and the uk is uh you
know like the rest of the west having to
react to events which are you know not
of our making so the the you know the
invasion of ukraine hard on the heels of
the the kovic crisis have obviously
prompted us to have to do some dramatic
and extraordinary things but we can do
those things because frankly we spent
the last 10 years repairing the damage
of the 08 financial crash and that's why
what george osborne did what philip
hammond did mattered so much because
that fiscal consolidation has given us
the space
to do what is required in the teeth of
an emergency that's why frankly
conservative economics makes sense so
that you have no concerns about all this
borrowing it's going to be loaded on to
future generations my children's general
i mean look i mean i you know we are all
very conscious of this and you know i i
absolutely believe that the state should
live within its means uh you know
whenever possible but you have to also
balance what we're seeking to do here
for the real economy in the near term
against that against that challenge
we're comfortable that this is the right
approach critically what we cannot do is
just allow this situation to play out
without a decisive intervention i think
what we're seeing from uh liz truss's
government is early decisive
intervention which will provide a
lasting framework critically so we're
not keeping coming back to those
intervals it's not like you know
you were in government for two months
this could have come
in the summer it couldn't because i
wasn't there wasn't a government with a
mandate to do this and i'm afraid as a
result of the situation we faced over
the summer
now
he's got the chancellor
the situation so you could have done
something earlier in the summer i'm
afraid to say we we weren't in the
position to do that we are now we're
acting today before that price cut comes
in let's just move on to your new brief
uh that's leveling up and and housing
minster just what is leveling up and
what does it mean to you what is
something leveling up is the uh
delivering of opportunity to all parts
of the country and the you know the
realities i represent a uh constituency
up on t side in the northeast and you
know the communities i represent are
proud are passionate about uh you know
their lives but you know let's be clear
the opportunity in places like loftus or
middlesbrough is not the same as it
would be here in westminster and we have
got to close that gap we've got to close
it through infrastructure investment
we've got to close it above all through
economic growth and the delivery of more
enterprise more
frankly more economic opportunity is is
is the is the absolute key to leveling
up and that's what i'm determined to
help deliver opportunities delivered
through fracking in people's
neighborhoods i mean we know how
unpopular fracking is with many
communities well we have to look at all
forms of uh energy extraction and this
again leads us into the
discussion that the prime minister will
be opening up
as part of her announcement uh today but
look if we want energy sufficient so we
have to look at every source including
clearly new nuclear more renewables and
there's you know fantastic news uh going
on with uh with technologies like
offshore win well the price just keeps
falling but yeah we also ought to look
at technologies like fracking we have to
do so in the most sensitive possible way
with community consent at the absolute
heart of our policies but there is a
balanced approach to this question the
net zero commitment that the government
has made by 2050 is critical it's
something i uh helped to push for when i
was
about venture it's something which i
passionately believe unlocks frankly the
greatest energy security as well as
economic economic opportunity but in the
near term we need all kinds of gas as a
transition fuel and that's something our
prime minister will be saying more about
later today move on to just one last
thing the new cabinet is you're a new
member on this cabinet you're in the old
one as well but uh we'll stick with this
new cabinet now uh why did you vote
against uh expanding same-sex marriage
to northern ireland in 2019. i made that
choice because uh candidly i believe in
devolution and the uh the situation we
faced in 2019 was that we didn't have a
functioning assembly in storm and i
don't believe uh that as a english mp
it's really my prerogative to be voting
on social issues in northern ireland
which are properly a matter for the
devolved assembly uh in in northern
ireland elected by the people of
northern ireland where clearly there are
different cultural and social uh
conditions to in the rest of the uk i
simply believe uh and i stand by my
decision that it wasn't for me to tell
others how to live their lives i
personally am all in favor of same-sex
marriage and i'm you know thrilled that
it's in place in england i've got many
many friends who live happily
in same-sex marriages but it isn't for
me to tell other people how to live
their lives in in parts of the country
where devolution is in place i believed
at the time and i i think i you know i
completely stand by that that it it was
right that they should have that that
that say over of what happened
but from politicians accountable to them
okay i mean it's very clear i appreciate
that mr clark um uh just fine let's go
back to fracking as well in the net zero
commitment so if you do expand fracking
um more extraction of gas from from
beneath the earth how are we gonna meet
those net zero commitments well we're
absolutely clear that net zero as i say
sits at the heart of our policies and
you know we've got to use gases as well
yeah by 2050 absolutely there is no
resilient for that commitment we've just
got you know wonderful new advances like
the hornet c2 uh offshore wind uh farm
which is the largest i think in in
europe and that's going to power 1.3
million homes that's just gone live
we've got the big decision which has
just been taken on size well uh c the
new nuclear power station but you know
we we cannot avoid the reality that gas
from russia has underpinned not just uh
britain but europe's wider energy
strategy that dependence has left us
desperately vulnerable it has to end now
and in the in the interim
we have to make sure that we're using
all available sources of domestic fuel i
think the public would think that's the
only sensible thing to do